♪ ♪
>> Tucker: IN JANUARY, SIMON &
SCHUSTER, THE GARGANTUAN
PUBLISHING HOUSE CANCELED THE
BOOK BY A SENATOR FROM MISSOURI,
JOSH HAWLEY, BECAUSE A MOB OF
DEMOCRATIC ACTIVISTS TOLD THEM
TO.
IT WASN'T THE FIRST TIME THEY'VE
DONE THINGS LIKE THIS, THEY DID
THE SAME THING TO MILO YOU
NOVELISTS BEFORE.
THEY TOOK A SECOND BOOK FROM
CANDACE OWENS, BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T LIKE HER POLITICS.
IT'S ALL IN A NEW BOOK I'VE JUST
WRITTEN, COMING OUT OF AUGUST BY
SIMON & SCHUSTER.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO CHECK IT OUT.
IN THE MEANTIME, IN THE FACE OF
THIS KIND OF CENSORSHIP, THERE
IS A NEW OPTION IN PUBLISHING WE
WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT, IT'S
CALLED ALL SEASONS PRESS, THE
COFOUNDER AND EDITOR IN CHIEF,
TOGETHER THEY WILL OFFER THIS
OPTION TO THE COUNTRY.
CONGRATULATIONS, THANK YOU FOR
COMING ON TONIGHT.
I WILL START WITH YOU, LOUISE.
WHY DOES A COUNTRY NEED THIS?
>> WE CREATED THE PRESS TO
PREVENT THE SILENCING OF
OPPOSING THOUGHTS.
WE ARE SET UP WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION, THE MEDIA, AND
BIG TECH TELLING US WHAT TO
THINK AND HOW TO THINK.
AT THE SAME TIME, INDOCTRINATING
OUR CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS.
THEY ARE ATTACKING OUR LANGUAGE,
AND OUR BASIC RIGHT OF FREE
SPEECH, AND ARE COMING FOR
EVERYONE.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
HOW WILL ALL SEASONS PRESS BE
DIFFERENT THAN SIMON & SCHUSTER?
>> AS WE SAID, WE ARE HERE FOR
ALL POINTS OF VIEW, WE SUPPORT
THE CONSERVATIVE MESSAGE, AND
THEY ARE TRYING TO SILENCE THAT
MESSAGE, WE FEEL THERE'S A REAL
VOID.
IT NOW THAT WE HAVE PUBLISHERS,
ALTHOUGH THEY ARE PUBLISHING
SOME CONSERVATIVE BOOKS, THEY
ARE ONLY PUBLISHING THOSE THEY
FEEL DON'T APPROACH SUBJECTS
THAT ARE CONSIDERED TABOO.
THERE'S ALL THIS SELECTION GOING
ON.
WE ARE HERE TO SUPPORT THE
SENATORS, DEPENDENTS, VOICES
WILL BE PUBLISHED BEFORE WHO ARE
NOW BEING IGNORED.
THEY ARE BEING CANCELED, BEING
CENSORED, WE FELT THAT THERE IS
REALLY ROOM FOR US AND A VOID TO
BE FILLED.
>> Tucker: YOU SPENT MANY
YEARS IN PUBLISHING.
CANDACE OWENS, ONE OF THE
BIGGEST NAMES IN PUBLISHING, HER
FIRST BOOK WAS A RUNAWAY
SUCCESS, HER COULD'VE TAKEN IT.
JOHN CARPER WHO RUNS IT, SAYS I
DON'T WANT IT.
SINCE I'M GETTING, THEIR
POLITICS ARE MORE IMPORTANT THAN
THEIR REVENUE.
THAT'S HOW IDEOLOGICAL THEY ARE.
>> I ALSO THINK THE PEOPLE WHO
WORK AT THE PUBLISHING HOUSES
ARE TRYING TO DICTATE WHAT THE
PUBLISHING HOUSES DO.
IT'S A BUSINESS FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
THE "WOKE" BOOKS WERE FUNDED BY
SOME OF THESE BIGGER BOOKS WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
AS A EDUCATION TO BE DONE THERE.
BE WHEN YOU'RE SEEING WHEN THEY
PUBLISH A CONSERVATIVE BOOK THAT
PEOPLE ACTUALLY READ, IT PAYS
FOR THE LITTLE BOUTIQUE CRAZY
PROJECTS THAT THE LUNATICS WHO
WORK THERE WOULD LIKE TO SEE?
>> I WOULD SAY THAT THE ARE
ABSOLUTELY FUNDED BY THE BIGGER
BOOKS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BUY THE BOOK,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO READ IT, IT'S
AMERICA.
YOU CAN CHOOSE NOT TO.
FOR US NOT TO PUBLISH THE
VOICES, FOR INSTANCE,
POLITICIANS WHO ARE ONLY IN
SOUND BITES, THEY SHOULD HAVE
LONG FORM, THEY SHOULD HAVE THE
OPTION TO DO SO.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> Tucker: GO AHEAD.
BECAUSE THE TIMES REPORTED TODAY
THAT THERE ARE SOME PUBLISHING
EXECUTIVES SAYING THAT IT WOULD
BE MORALLY UNACCEPTABLE TO
PUBLISH BOOKS BY TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS.
WE SIGNED A STATEMENT LIKE THAT
IS CRAZY AND COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE TO US.
WE ARE PROBABLY IN OUR FIRST
LIST, PUBLISHING TO HIGH-LEVEL
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS,
MARK MEADOWS, AND PETER NAVARRO.
>> Tucker: GOOD FOR YOU, AND
TO SHAME ON THEM FOR ABANDONING
THE LONG-STANDING COMMITMENT
THAT AMERICAN PUBLISHING HATS
FOR FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
IT